eating me that's pretty tasty so it's no
surprise that most people do it you
probably do but are they making a
mistake and leaving half the human race
and slaved by patriarchy and D'Alessio
parson is a sociology professor at Penn
State University she's sitting right
next to me on the set right now in a
recent piece for something called the
Journal of feminist geography professor
D'Alessio parson says that eating meat
entrenches hegemonic masculinity and
that for women going vegetarian quote
pushes back against the patriarchy and
may even eliminate the gender binary
itself professor D'Alessio parson who
joins us tonight professor thanks for
coming on yeah thank you
so you wrote this in the Journal of
feminist geography my issue decom so I
haven't seen it but tell me you say that
vegetarianism helps women push back
against the patriarchy and makes men
more egalitarian and respectful how does
that work yeah I mean so that's not a
direct quote but that's that is very
well summarized okay so you must have
good people working oh for sure so what
how do you connect eating meat
carnivorous behavior with the patriarchy
well I said I brought you a gift
yes use your imagination okay
and I think this book might help okay
okay so I read it this year I have you
ever heard of Octavia Butler no never
Oh do you like science fiction Oh tons
yes you do yeah okay so I have a book by
Octavia Butler coach Willis brood I
can't remember this camera Willis brood
okay and that's like a dystopian
feminist novel about what no no you guys
read it it's about divorce you got to
read it to folk' right well tell me how
does do you think that being a
vegetarian helps defeat the patriarchy
well wait first you gonna read it yeah
absolutely Bock yeah thank you
all right and this is the one I'm
reading okay and for another partial
response check out this one so we've
we've sold a couple of feminist books
here on the book club
what terminus there tell me imagine
let's get to the nub of it how I eat
meat yeah how am i perpetuating the
patriarchy by doing so
well like okay there's a several ways
and one of the ways in which we
perpetuate patriarchy is when we take up
a little bit too much space right and
eating meat is a diet that requires more
space on the planet well okay it
requires more resources to produce meat
than it does to produce plant-based food
but what does that have to do I
understand that and I know the
environmental one against eating meat
but you seem to suggest in your piece
that there's something about meat
specifically that makes men dangerously
masculine and that men who refrained
from meat become easier to deal with
there is a more egalitarian I seem to
say in my piece you said you didn't read
it yet well I have the summary right
here well you got you to read my words
well I think they've got quotation marks
around oh okay
do you believe that eating meat makes
men more masculine why are you um I
guess I'm wondering why you're so
concerned about like men becoming more
or less masculine
like this are you really professor
because I feel like this may be a
performance art let's performin no no
I'm a professor okay I do I believe that
when you come together two individuals
come together right um you co produce
knowledge what we were saying before you
didn't finish college you co-produced
knowledge yes so you tell me this if I
stopped eating meat woulda how would I
be better I don't think it's about
better or worse right I think it's a
question of how much space are we as
individuals taking up so how much space
are we taking up when it comes to what
we consume the tea we drink I'll really
like tea oh I had a package for you I'll
give it to you later the things let me
just ask you this really on our body and
what we put in our households how much
is face do you promise you're real
professor yeah okay what does it mean to
be a real professor I'm asking one last
final question which is I'm getting the
sense from what I have read whether or
not you wrote it as another question but
I think that you did that when men
stopped eating meat they change in ways
that you think are good is that true I
think it's
helpful that that men stop that all
people consider how much meat they
choose to put in their bodies I'm not
here to mandate anything right we all
make our individual level choices our
individual choice is incredibly
important right Adam Smith yes right
we're just talking about in the green
room I will say I've come away with too
strong impressions from this interview
one I like you more really but I know
much less what does that mean I don't
know will you have me back you discard
us we can talk about professor thank you
thank you for joining us all right